hello everyone welcome to another
YouTube hangout super excited to be here
again with you today I have a special
guest Michelle the fear girl polar who
has an awesome YouTube channel where she
is helping people overcome fear by
showing her own experiences of
overcoming fear and she's doing a new
challenge every day everything from
getting her first Brazilian wax to
skydiving to walking around in a bikini
in New York City and a whole bunch of
other fun things to get over fear and
we're gonna talk to you guys today about
fear and what might be holding you back
and maybe give you some idea suggestions
to help you overcome your fear so
Michelle welcome aboard I was just
saying before I love the the believe in
the background there fits it's my thing
I'm so glad you catch that I was never
it's amazing what what your eye gets
drawn to you know I just I believe
instantly and then I said there's a
little YouTube icon thing behind you on
the other side that's what I noticed
first except some people would see that
home crazy drunk the yeah from MoMA I
love it so so talk to us about theater
why did you start this project why is it
so important what are you hoping to
accomplish through your your channel and
what you're doing and kind of lessons
for entrepreneurs okay so it all started
last year when I decided to face my
fears in order to enjoy life to the
fullest I realized that I had a pretty
decent life it's not like I had a bad
life at all I had the job I thought I
wanted
the husband I dreamt about my still
dream about I had everything in my life
was in place I just never felt I was
truly enjoying every second and living
my life I was constantly thinking about
the next thing and trying to control
every situation our wounded plus my
favorite answer was always no I
I'd rather always be comfortable stay in
my comfort zone and be surrounded by the
familiar I would I didn't like to be
exposed to the unknown and that way I
realized that when I moved to New York
two years ago ready
I was hot and during my life I was not
enjoying New York and this was my dream
to move here and that's when I decided
to start facing my fears as a way to
really enjoy this city so the way you're
supposed to
otherwise you're closing yourself to
experiences to opportunities to life
differentiate and that's when I decided
to face 100 fears it was a class project
actually we were all commissioned to do
100-day project whatever you want to do
do it for 100 days and I took this
opportunity to do something big that
could potentially change my life and he
did in every single way possible I
changed my career I changed my way of
even looking at myself looking at life
through this project and what I did is I
faced one fear a day for 100 days every
day I would choose something that I'm
scared about that I've never done before
and something also that I'm curious
about but it's not just anything or I
wouldn't do something that is risky that
would put my lives at risk for anything
things that would truly help me enjoy
life to the fullest and I would do this
I would report myself and then edit a
video and put it on YouTube so I faced
40 fears one after the other and then
around the day 40 the project went viral
and that's when I realized the potential
that I've had and how amazing it is that
in the face of fear and you put yourself
vulnerable out there you are allowing
other people to feel like there
the only ones who are scared of things
and that they're not alone in this
we are all in the same thing it's just
that people don't share as much this
part of life
they share their fears or the way they
have approached or over here and I was
doing that and that's when it went viral
and I started receiving messages from
people saying that thanks to my project
they change their life and we change the
way of looking at the fear and I never
thought like I started this project just
to become a greater person myself so
it's not expecting any of this response
and that's what I realized that power
that it had when you share your
experiences and that's what I'm doing
now after I finished the 100 days and I
did a TEDx as my 100th fear I realized
that I wanted to keep encouraging more
people to face their fears and my way of
doing it is I speak conferences schools
and events and companies and everything
but also I keep promoted I keep doing my
youtube channel where every week what a
video where I'm talking about fear and
it's a different aspect of life and then
I have the platform hello fierce calm
where I'm encouraging people to send me
their own stories overcoming fears to
encourage others to face their own fears
because what I realize is that I don't
have all the fears in the world and
people who are asking me to face fears
that I don't have just that they could
see how I approach those situations so
for example they were asking me can you
face a fear of heights and I don't have
fear of heights or it can you face fears
of crowded spaces and I don't have those
fears but other people do so if other
people start documenting and sharing the
way they approach their own fears then
maybe more people can benefit from those
experiences and that's what the platform
it's only ah I love it well you already
have some fans who are watching live and
chatting up Rishi Cup TV saying that
Michelle did an amazing TED talk on fear
so some fans and believe nation already
and think about entrepreneurs like my
honesty entrepreneurs want to be
entrepreneurs a lot of them have huge
fears in starting the business and
taking that risk they may have this you
know great idea that they want to chase
but the people around them and telling
them it's stupid and they shouldn't do
it and the voice inside their head is
telling them don't do it you know who
are you to do it and they have like
moments of boldness we get all excited
and then you shrink back down to your
regular life what would you what would
your advice be after kind of overcoming
a hundred different figures who can
advise me to these entrepreneurs who are
afraid to get started or afraid to bet
on themselves so many things it's all
definitely
so for example the first one I always
try to identify and when I'm making a
decision each option I have moving
forward is the option that is based on
growth and which option is the one that
is based on safety and I would not
recommend people to choose the option
that is based on safety if they want to
move forward because that option will
only make them happy for a little bit
and it will always be like very slow the
way you progressed in life if you always
keep choosing the fears fear based
option or safety based option so there's
a quote from Maslow that I love and it
we will either steps forward into growth
or step back into safety so we always
have these two options in front of
ourselves and we have to identify and
it's really important that you don't
convince yourself that you want to go
after the safety option yes because it
makes you feel safe and this applies for
everything in life
entrepreneurship but also when you're
with someone maybe you want something
better out of life and that person is
holding you back
but that person gives a safety so it's
comfortable to stay there instead of you
know going with a both option anything
that the way to identify which is the
growth phase option is always the scary
one so you know but you're scared about
something then that's the one and that's
that you should do it like soon as you
identify that you are scared of
something
I think that that is a good sign I think
that that is something that you want
even more and that's why you're so
scared about it and we the other thing I
was going to say about overcoming that
fear okay so I think that you always
have to start and that is what you
should be aiming for at least start if
you don't start and you keep these ideas
in your mind and you keep older also
asking other people are going to what
they think people don't know what they
want right now Steve Jobs always said
that people don't know or know Henry
Ford right they don't know what they
want they would say if you ask them what
do you want they would say fastest plus
their horse instead of a car cuz they
don't know so I think that asking people
around you is not the answer I think
that if you truly believe in what you're
doing and you know but there is a higher
purpose to your intention then
consulting with others is not going to
help you go past what go past that for
example my husband just quit his job two
or three weeks ago to join me full time
on what I'm doing on this mission that I
have and now it's that we have together
and we were in this too situation in
this to option situation where we we we
needed the stability but stability is a
safety based option if we go for the
stability which is him standing his
danger his regular job well I tried to
do this on my own
and who never really going to move
forward but we also wanted independence
so where we were in between independence
and stability we identify stability else
the safety option and independence as
the growth option so we decided to move
forward and if he would have listened to
everyone around him everybody was saying
you're crazy Michelle can travel on her
only Michelle can do the same on her own
and yeah I can it's not going to really
take us where we want to think and not
in the time frame that we want to get
there so she's time to be bold about it
and quit and now we've been working on
so I'm really building what we believe
in and we know we're on the right track
just because we're not doing this for a
selfish purpose we're doing this because
I think that everything you do in life
if you have a real purpose to help
others then it should happen for you if
you really work hard on it we have a
mission here and the mission is to we
say that facing fears is contagious - -
the mission here is to want to gather
message so more people can see it more
people can benefit from this from the
stories from the tasks from the videos
who constantly try to inspire others to
go after their fears and that's the
beauty of this project and what I
believe is that everything that you want
to do then is it's that thing to benefit
other people then you should totally do
it and not think about this as a selfish
act but as a thing that you're providing
to the world so for example if you want
to read a book and you're doubtful about
it
why would you keep from the world your
knowledge or your three a TV that so I
think when I look at things that way I
feel more empowered to go after the
things that I feel deep inside that I
should fight for I love it I love that
example if you have two options one a
security one is a growth go for the
growth one even though that may seem
super scary to you so like getting there
as a conscious decision like I'm
thinking about which path should I take
what do you tell the people who don't
have the conscious decision making yet
whether they're just defaulting without
even thinking about it default to play
the lesser game to play the safe path
the secure path without sitting down to
think about it - just naturally always
say no like you were you don't even
realize that they're always saying no
they don't realize they're holding
themselves back what kind of advice
would you give them it's hard because
maybe they're not even questioning what
their purpose is in life
and they're not they don't even know
this other option exists so for I have
that problem you get the people that
watch my videos and let they come to my
talks is because there is other
nonconformist who want more out of life
and they meet that extra push but people
that they don't know and they just
settle with whatever life throws their
way then they're not even watching this
video probably right they're not even
following you or neither you're on their
day job just getting things done and
leaving on autopilot which is so sad but
definitely would be amazing if other
people around them would share these
kind of things with them if other people
running would identify you know what I
have a friend that she's leaving on
autopilot and then if that person tries
to talk to this other person and maybe
shares
inspirational leaders like what we're
doing here then they would be doing a
much greater good and that's what I
tried to do with people close to me I
try to identify my friends weren't doing
things and they're not even conscious
about what how they're leaving their
life and I try to approach them and I
try to sell okay in my try to paint a
picture for them how would your life be
different if you weren't afraid to
disappoint others if you weren't afraid
of missing out if you want to pray of
all these things all those links on the
you know the Pyramid of Maslow so we
have the basic needs like food shelter
those are all the biological needs and
then we have the belonging episode 15 me
and so many people just live their life
trying to fulfill those fulfill itself
the self esteem of the belonging that
they do anything to belong so I have
friends that in order to belong and be
part of what their breasts are doing
they just go and have babies they just
go ahead and get married and not because
we've been passionate about that because
they want to belong and do what
everybody else is doing and the same
thing with the job so for example I went
to school to New York I went to grad
school and we graduated and everybody
started looking for jobs
and I felt that huge pressure that oh my
god everyone's looking for job and I
want to keep facing my fears keep
building my channel and start this
through the air that has not a specific
path and is not defined and I have to
make it from Hell so but I felt that
pressure like everybody supplying maybe
I should do the same and I think that
someone that many people would allow
that fear to coming away and dictate
their decisions and that is sad because
they're acting out of fear and not out
of passion in that sense I love it well
after I've gone through all of these
days of fear what do you still have as a
fear like what's still left what are you
still afraid of now I'm still afraid of
many many things that I need to face
moving forward there are for example
fear of motherhood is something that I
constantly think about and I try to
always define that if I really want this
because everybody's doing it and I feel
incredible pressure to do it and my
parents are asking for it and you know
oh my friends are in that path right now
or if I wanted because I just see myself
as a leader in my house budget you know
having kids that I can really teach them
everything that I'm learning and I know
that whenever that time comes I will be
reaching out that is one of my biggest
biggest fears motherhood for sure and
also because I want to keep doing my
career my career takes a lot of
traveling how can I travel with kids and
kids favorite Dean so that is the huge
fear that I do have moving forward of
course we have a fear of failure that is
something that we have to face every
single day every time I put a youtube
video it's funny because I call my
Wednesday's fearless Wednesdays because
that's they upload a video and I'm
supposed to encourage people to be a
little bit more fearless that day and
every Wednesday I'm terrified that no
one will like it that it will have no
exposure no views no comments no
engagement and my husband tells me you
should call depression Wednesday's not
fearless
it's a fear we have to face every day
but the important thing is that we don't
allow our fears to stop us to hold us
back
so everyone said even though I don't get
the results I wanted or the engagement
or anything that's not a reason for me
to stop it's like the other way around
it's a reason for me to improve and say
how can I make this video a bit better
how can I make it next week that more
people engaged and that's what I've been
trying and I failure I'm seeing as the
end point of my senses of my story I see
it as a pivoting point so every time I'm
feeling like okay what did I do wrong
how can I make it better and then I call
all my friends my friends that are
honest not like the ones that are just
there to just tell me you're awesome but
the ones that tell me yeah I was a good
bu but maybe you can list assistances
those were the friends that I like to
call and ask them please be completely
honest with me because that is the only
way that we can grab failure and turn it
into something greater like it both
failure to so yeah something them bring
better in furthest things in the future
I love it well we've got a bunch of
people watching live and filling up the
chat stream and asking questions so low
and I want to recognize some of them and
let's get to some reader questions first
up is sue she'll who's saying how do I
start anew after I've had a bad past Oh
like change the past holding you back
what do you recommend there so I think
that well if you've had a backpack
definitely it's a great way to learn
from that and really not just like close
the door of it and close the book on
what happened and try to start over but
open that book again go back and really
analyze everything have that happened
there and why why it happened and learn
as much as you can I think that you can
be your best teacher and your failures
can be like the best content that you
can learn from do you forward and yeah
so that's what I keep questioning
everything I do in my life like okay so
this happened
and I don't think I did it because this
is and it's not like I do that exercise
because I want to go back and fix what I
did in the past but is how can I grab
this knowledge that now I understand
because I think also Steve Jobs says
like you cannot connect the thoughts
moving forward but you can always
connect the moving backwards so now that
you're past that that path how can you
connect the dots and say okay so this is
what it did long and this how I can make
it better at this I don't know learn
from your own experiences then and also
if you can get some experts to share
those experiences with them and see
their point of view and what might long
learn from other points of view and
every time you do something I send it to
all my professors I just finished a talk
that I will be giving that world
domination summit and I just send it to
a professor that she's really good at
writing and thinking about audiences I
also send it to a professor that he's
amazing in psychology and behavior human
behavior so now I'm getting back all
those points of views from different
experts in their fields I love it the
the audience is freaking out about the
belief sign to get some some quick love
with my channels to have belief
somewhere in the backdrop by the scoring
points is good okay so the next question
from Rishi Cup TV she's the one who saw
your TED talk and it's like super jazzed
up and excited about you coming on the
channel so her question is Michelle of
all the fears that you face so far which
one was the hardest for you and why well
so it's funny that question because I
have a hard time answer anything because
they all of the fears were the hardest
one before I did them so every time I
faced a fear was like okay that wasn't
that bad but tomorrow
I have to do this and I'm going to freak
out and I'm going to die and I make up
this huge like dark cloud in my mind of
things that could go wrong and I'm so
terrified of what's going to happen next
and then I do it and then again the same
feeling is like oh okay
wasn't that but but the next one so
every challenge I think that it's the
worst before you do it so never think
that facing a period is easy of course
there are fears are easier than others
but for example [ __ ] nude in front of a
during class I thought I was going to
die I thought to do it from there what
if I can't just hit it up and I did it
and I learned so much in those 15
minutes that I spent get posting that I
don't ever want to take that experience
back I learned a lot it's not like I
wanna do it again but if I have to I
would do it because it is hot as bad as
we thought or skydiving I really thought
I was going to pass out in the airplane
going up and it didn't happen I was just
there I was experiencing and in that
moment I try to be very mindful and
understand the situation and say wow I'm
experiencing life right now I'm
experiencing sphere I'm experiencing
adrenaline Oh try to understand all
these feelings and emotions that you're
having and embrace that I now embrace
fear as an emotion and I'd like to
understand that every time a figure
comes in my way that is a chance for me
to grow that's just for me to learn
something new to maybe fold down get
hurt
but then have something to learn from so
fears you are a good sign that's a good
sign I think yeah and the one way the
one fear I was about to just leave
before the fear was like I'm not doing
this and I did it at the end was jumping
from a cliff into the water that's
something that I've been terrified to do
since I was very little all my friends
would do and I would never even try and
this time we drove two hours to go to a
place and we were there and I couldn't
jump it was like it was beyond me I
think it goes from being a fear to be la
Sophia it becomes a little bit
irrational of course nothing will happen
you will fall you man in the water
that's it and it was in a you know water
park there are no rocks or anything kids
were doing it it was safe so the fear
becomes irrational and I was
about to just leave but that's when I
decided to start counting backwards at
three two one and I had no choice so I
don't but that was I think one of the
hardest ones for me interesting people
are asking me now what my biggest fear
is so they're me they're putting me on
the spot here thank you thank you for
that appreciated so I have some some
ones that I don't feel it hurt me too
much like I'm afraid of heights so I
don't I haven't gone skydiving you know
I don't go bungee jumping I'd be afraid
of doing that jump off the water thing
into the pool um I'm afraid of losing
control I like to be in control of my
body so like I don't like roller
coasters my roller coaster I don't let
go and just enjoy I mean good job I'm in
control constantly fight it's quite it
sucked I wouldn't do well on space
travel or anything like that
I don't know I don't know how much those
hold me back though I like it's not like
I've massively want to fix those that's
the biggest one that that was crippling
in my career was I I have a fear of
letting people down and I fear that I
won't provide enough value to them and
it would lead to me cancelling meetings
or just hoping that somebody cancels on
me or I get some big speaking gig and
then hope that they would cancel on me
the day off so I wouldn't have to go
because I'd be afraid of not not not
giving people value and I've gotten way
better at that I don't know that I don't
know if that's still in there somewhere
it might be but I had to really do some
work for a couple years to just
recognize that and push through the fear
and understand that hey every time I've
done this it's been great and I feel
great at the end of it and the other
people feel great too why am I so afraid
of this every time I just doing that
enough maybe I just condition myself
that not be as afraid like even
something like this I would be afraid of
getting on the call with somebody and
having them on my channel or having a
conversation just worried that I
wouldn't bring you and I thought I
wouldn't bring my audience enough value
so I don't know at what point that
really just disappeared or maybe it's
still lingering somewhere
but that was a big las vegas type of
crippling thing earlier in my career
that prevented me from from being the
person that i could be that's really
interesting and i think that when you
mention it's exactly what you have to do
so identify the fears that can keep you
from growing your career or from moving
forward because we will always have
fears and you don't have to face them
all because that would take a lot of
time and energy but if rollercoasters or
Heights disappear that it's not really
preventing you from getting where you
want to be then that nutrients focusing
that much of that fear but it's the fear
of feeling letting people down it's a
little bit like the the imposter
syndrome fear that you feel that right
have you heard of all the imposter
imposter syndrome no butBut I can I can
guess by the name yeah it's that feeling
that yeah you're on husband and I think
that every person goes through a lot and
one thing that I really like that I
heard is we are in this earth to fulfill
a purpose to do something and if you
know what that isn't I'm sure you do
know your purpose I now know my purpose
then you have to be comments I love that
advice about becoming it it's not taken
for granted that you should be
immediately that person and and if
you're not then go and find something
else to do so for example I now have to
become a speaker because that's the
route I decided to take as a way to
inspire more people and I see that it
brings results to me I feel great when I
do it to the audience they feel amazing
when they hear me speak that's the
feedback that I've been getting so I
have to keep doing until I become that
speaker and I have the confidence to say
I on speaker and go and speak without
having the fear inside of me that I will
let down I love it Victoria is writing
in saying why don't they teach about why
don't they teach about fear in college
yes I think they should definitely have
maybe I should go to teaching college
but definitely for me college is one of
the markets that I really want to tap
into because I see how when you're about
to graduate when you're in college you
start making some decisions to either
please other people lie to your parents
or a society and I mean other people's
expectations and you have so much
pressure to succeed and be someone
because we just graduated and it
shouldn't be that way we should have the
time to find what you're good at and
what you love and try to combine those
two and bring value to the world
do whatever you would love to to enjoy
without doing so definitely colleges is
a market that really excites me to go to
speak so I've been speaking at companies
and organizations but last time I spoke
I went to my high school not to my
college where I graduated scared in
Savannah and they brought me to speak at
the graduation to all the graduating
students it was like 5,000 people in
there and I was freaking out I was so
scared and when it was my turn
they put all the lights on and I could
see all the students and Wow
just to have that feeling that now get
to inspire people that are going to go
into the world hopefully they will grab
my advice and use it and it will stay
with them so I instead of feeling
anxious or nervous and felt so excited
like I turned my fear into excitement
and I was able to deliver a message in
the best way possible
and that's when I realized I'm gonna
keep speaking to students so in this
month by the end of the month I'm
actually going to California and I'm
going to speak at all girls high school
and I cannot tell you how excited I am
about that opportunity all girls like
500 girls I will be opening their spoon
here and I need to even write this book
from scratch and I'm so excited about it
that I don't do it yeah I try to keep
myself from doing it because I just
found it looks so good I care so much
about it I love it I think you need to
teach more believed in in school too
question from mr. reader 324 this is
that me but I think you can rent rule 82
he says Evan
naturally introvert if so hand you
handle YouTube channel I am I'm a
massive introvert I'm not the guy
talking to people making connections at
airports and you know networking events
and going to conferences I don't go to
conferences unless I'm speaking I need a
long time I need like decompress time
where I'm not around people there's just
something about entrepreneurs has met
connecting michelle's what's your why
like I when I'm about entrepreneurs I
just get excited I want to share I want
to help them I can see the impact that I
can have on somebody's business and so
that has led me to again to Michele's
more like what's the path this led me
down a youtube half and we have almost
400,000 subscribers but I filmed once a
day I do these hangouts I film once a
week and I do these hangouts once a week
and the rest of the week I'm doing
introvert stuff like I'm not taking
calls or meetings or you know I need
time by myself just totally by myself
anytime with my wife and just the two of
us and nobody else and and I don't enjoy
going to parties
I need the limit social I keep like if
it's one of those days we have three
parties to go to I need it I need the
next day to be awesome
I can't like I just shut down so there
was a big foodie we put up recently from
Ellen Ellen DeGeneres top ten rules for
success is she's an introvert - she is
she says she's an introvert yeah which
is a surprise and people are surprised
honestly I'm an introvert but you
learned that come out of your shell for
the Y for the purpose of what you're
trying to get done and when it's
entrepreneurship I can go forever but
anything else small talk and social
settings and whatever I just go back in
and just fine like I don't I don't I
don't I don't want to be an extra I
don't want to enjoy that I'm happy with
it I just need that time to decompress
I don't know Michelle if you're
introverted or not and how you got over
that or maybe you just massively
extroverted I actually never in my life
thought about the concept of introvert
versus extrovert and never question Who
I am and so now I've been questioning
myself this a lot because since I was
little I always crave attention and that
doesn't seem like a characteristic from
an introvert right craving attention
and I've seen so it was very like this
happened with my brother was born I
stopped getting all the attention that I
was getting and I'm like I want to be an
engineer when in fact so I've always
been thrilled about this idea of
speaking in front of an audience
doing my youtube channel of being in
front of the camera and everything but
at the same time I'm not this person
that in a group you will see like
screaming and talking loud and engaging
I'm not I think I am an introvert when
it comes to speaking to strangers to
speaking but maybe if it's my group of
friends I feel very comfortable about I
can there be the exterior I'd like to be
but when I surround myself with
strangers and it's funny because now my
husband and that keeps with me all the
time and he comes with me to other
speaking engagements it has to remind me
to be nice which is weird is that
please remember to be not you're not
nice be nice to the person that's
organizing media fans and everybody else
there they need to like you they like
you then you're good and yeah normally I
would just be very quiet and to the
point this so I think I'm honest of both
and I've been very I admire a lot of
introverts that they know their
insurance and they're still making so
big in the world and fighting with
they're in Traverse ok this is not a
word like fighting their their system in
order to to really bring to the world
what I really need to bring so for
example you for example I mean I don't
know if you know the designer Jessica
Wallace she is a big introvert but still
she's an amazing designer so she travels
the world speaking to people about
design and that I even heard that simon
Sinek was an introvert which I was
surprised about it to hear that Ellen
DeGeneres I think it's even more at
hireable if you are an introvert and
you're doing disparate impact in the
world means that you are fighting things
that certain people don't have to buy it
just becomes listen to them someone left
in the comments Evan I can help you with
your each of your problem
I don't see it as a problem I see it as
a huge asset like if I was I tried to be
an extrovert I wouldn't win I love that
I'm introvert and I just need to design
a life around that right just like
everybody needs to design a life around
your strengths I don't focus on
improving my weaknesses because I'm not
actually where do I see it as a huge
problem I think thinking it's a problem
is a problem so I designed a schedule
and the life around what what best suits
me and my personally my lifestyle it's
amazing how quickly half an hour flies
and we said a little early - Michelle
you're sharing insane wisdom I really
enjoyed the chat and the vibe for people
who are curious about you want to learn
more about what you're doing the
projects you're working on what's coming
up next how they can support you what's
the best way to to connect and keep
getting more hits of Michelle so
definitely follow my youtube channel I
just uploaded a video today I normally
upload on Wednesdays but my channel is
hello fears you can find it there in
YouTube and yeah so you keep getting
inspired by every week hopefully you're
learning about fear and then if you can
follow a little fierce calm which is the
platform where I'm adding courageous
stories from everyday people every day
and if you want to see some of my
speaking like demo reel and is nut you
can't go to Michelle Poehler calm where
I have all of it
so thank you so much order for this Evan
it's awesome
I loved it we've linked it up down in
the description below so you guys can
check that out and learn more about
Michelle
guys thank you so much for watching
there's been a ton of question that we
weren't able to get to but you know
that's what happens in half an hour
Michelle thank you so much for your
wisdom and your grace and your your
sharing and your honesty I really
appreciate guys watching continue to
believe and we'll see you soon my thank
you so much it was great